today we're going to finish follows by
similar cross section and you may recall
voice very similar cross section are a
little bit intimidating at the beginning
because you lose some of that
predictability about what kind of shape
this is going to be when we were looking
at slicing shells no matter what kind of
shake you got you knew it's going to be
ground it's going to be you got the same
kinds of formulas cutting up again and
again you got your PI R squared minus a
squared for Andy other slices and then
you've got your facility racal shells my
job remember when you yeah good you cut
out you cut out your solution shell
right when you dissect it you just get
your two PI R and your age so you get
the same formula again again and of
course you've got your you know your
appropriate delta x delta white whatever
but when you have a look at similar
cross-section it just blows open the
door and it's just like whatever you
want that's the hardest thing about them
however as you'll see like especially
will get cylindrical shells sometimes
the integral you get out of it and just
the algebra room that how many integrals
you got in all the boundaries
algebraically is hard almost universally
you'll find volunteers my similar
cross-section the mathematics topic is
easier okay so morning actually we're
okay we're at capacity I don't know it
up so you will find that mathematics is
not difficult which is visualizing
what's going on so for those of you who
just work walked in this is where we're
going to begin we're going to build this
volume step by step so what you've got
here is two graphs you've got y equals
plus X and you've got y equals negative
kha'zix between not and plant food and
I'm doing this like as a normal graph
because this is just looking straight
down and looking at the base so here's
the idea you don't necessarily need to
draw these pants on but from this base I
want you to imagine having areas having
rectangles that are all the
like this and each one of these is going
to form the base of a triangle okay so
what's going to extend up from here do
you remember the last time we looked at
a circular base and we extend it up
squares yes so from here we're going to
extend up triangles but the question of
course is what kind of triangle would
you like so now to demonstrate this
right we need to take this diagram and
draw next to it our kind of 3d on an on
an angle view of this so if you put your
y-axis heading sort of off into the
distance and you've still got your x
axis which is horizontal now this will
be a little bit challenging I find this
difficult to I need to a bit more of
this because you're viewing at an angle
things that were symmetrical before I'm
no longer symmetrical so you want to try
and do this as best as you can so my
advice is on the y axis mark out your
negative 1 and your one which even
though we're putting perspective on this
we don't have like I'm we don't have a
vanishing point in our in our diagram so
I don't know if you guys are familiar
with how vanishing points work if i put
say how many do I know I've just happen
to I think that'd be fun if I wanted to
draw a cube with a vanishing with two
vanishing points like this and this this
is the idea that things do you actually
get small up with perspective so for
example I would have something like this
and you take a here other faces of my
cube and you can see right eye candy
this one this one you can see for
example this edge is clearly shorter
looking in this entrance exactly what
things do in in the real world right but
here we're imagining like this thing
just goes on forever and there's no
perspective distance changing so that's
why this should be the same so that we
can make our diagram
accurate was possibly care here comes
the tricky bit I now want to do these
beards but this one's squashed over the
top of its squash and this bottom one is
stretched out you see that should be
that's still plan to it's still a right
angle it's just we're viewing it from a
funny angle ok so I'm going to draw a
shape kind of like this ok so you see it
properly bless you ok now we don't try
too many of these because your diagram
gets rapidly confusing so I'm going to
draw maybe I think I'll just go with two
for now I'm going to draw a couple of
these sort of flat basis right so I'm
going to draw one of the long ones and
one of the short ones ok now this
particular HSC question what that asks
us to do is to create a series of
triangles and what binds them is that
they're all isosceles triangles and the
isosceles the equal length of these
triangles are all one unit inlet one
unit in them ok now just think about
this for a second you can actually see
I've already drawn one offer if you
imagine at x equals 0 I should put some
axis on this label and thanks on the
y-axis at x equals 0 if you were to
imagine using this part here this
interval as a base and in the oil which
triangle can I construct on top of that
such that the two equal lengths because
you know these lengths will change the
bases will keep changing but I want
their equal lengths that go up to be one
in each right where will that triangle
be and the answer is it will be on the
actual line this is it in fact because
if you imagine that's the base right and
then it's like okay from here I need a
sign that's going to be one unit long
but if it's exactly one unit long it's
going to go from here and it's just
going to end there right in the middle
like it's going to lay flat and it's
going to do the same from the opposite
end ok but as you move further in what
happens is it's like well if I went one
unit down this way I'm
to lift off the axis in order to still
be one and still connect okay so what
you want to do is draw a little vertical
line here okay because I'm going to come
off the access and then you've got your
two sides everything so you have a very
flat triangle on this end of the diagram
okay as you move across but you can see
here again if I have my a 1 and x 1
they're starting to do this you see
they're sort of coming up right and here
they're gonna be quite tall so again
draw a vertical line that suppose you
can call that as exs if you like but
it's going to be quite tall okay and
there's one last triangle not really
triangle that we're going to put in here
which is on the end here okay now just
like over here right you had a long base
and so your two sides are just like flat
okay but as you get from this end over
here and you progress across that way it
goes toilet toilet all at all until you
get to the point where it's like well
look my base is only there's no base so
therefore the two edges as it were
standing right next to each other make
sure she got quite that tall okay so you
can see I've got a series of triangles
in here I suppose I value you probably
could feed him one more in the middle
but I'm happy with that for now when I
have my series of triangles you can see
they get taller Anton's well up into
this point so like with the square with
the circular base and the square
profiles right you kind of get this
reach along here okay I'm in fact going
to draw that line my man who makes your
color as well so you can see what's
going on
so it's a weird shape right it's a weird
shape it's quite hard to see him whoever
I told you it's a problem of vision
interestingly enough you can actually
work out everything you need to hear by
drawing one more diagram a simple one
you don't need to add more detail to
this you've got all the officially you
can actually work out the volume however
like even though I've said to you many
times draw diagrams so you can
understand it better because they even
work it out here I actually think you've
developed all the understanding you need
but that doesn't mean you know what
you're working out like you calculate
you do all you crunch the numbers yeah I
have a number at the end what am I even
doing so I spent some time last night
drawing now I had to do it here I was
contemplating doing it for you here I
was contemplating doing it for you like
on the board and doing it live but I
just couldn't I couldn't convincingly do
it so it would be easier to see ok so
here's the shape and you can see I
because I did it before looks as if out
of my axes are more stretched out too
you've got your cos x line and you're
negative cuz x line right and here is
this region i haven't drawn any of the
triangles in yet ok so what I did is I
drew it and I time-lapse that's
hurtfully this ends up being a little
crime here we go ok now i just had to
have these are the bases right I
alternative color so be a little easy to
see I need to mark out where all of the
tops of the triangles would be and then
I started drawing triangles now know
there are lots of them and it feels a
bit like while my eyes okay so i did
this to make it a little bit easier to
see ok so do you see the shape that's
emerging ok what you've got is it's kind
of like an opera house he sort of thing
yeah like these are the sales this is
what you end up with I make it a little
bit clearer there you go ok so this is
the shape we're actually don't now do
you need a diagram this amazing ok I
disagree 15 minutes to draw and i submit
it up someone do you need a great this
amazing to work out the volume clearly
not ok but i think just as
mathematicians right like you want to
know what is it
I'm doing also now that you've got an
idea a better idea of this shape when we
arrived a number at the end I'm going to
ask you apart from looking at an answer
like a solution how do you know we're in
the right ballpark or not I want you to
leave this shape singe it into your
retina okay cuz I'm about to turn it off
and think about well okay what's a way
that I could remember when we were doing
this [ __ ] keep it what it look like
something like this do you remember this
guy right you're kinda right so we had a
love like a secret show and I said okay
we came up with a nutbar but I said well
can you approximate this and all we did
was we said just imagine his personal
curve we straightened that out and then
it became a cylinder another silver and
it was easy to work out you're in the
right ball mark I'm not going to spoil
it for ya I just wonder what would you
compare this to because at the end of
this when we get a number on I will
compare this to something just to
confirm that we're in the right arm
right the zone of solutions but what
would you do without me telling you
right so you have a think about it okay
shall we work out this opera house sale
vol 3 do it